hey what's up guys mkbhd here i'm back
and this is the super nexus project so a
lot of people have been asking recently
since the nexus 4 came out if it's a
good enough upgrade from the current
nexus which is the galaxy nexus and
there are a lot of reasons that actually
make that a tough decision to make the
nexus 4 does have updated specs
internally and it is running an updated
version of android jelly bean 4.2 jelly
bean which has some new features but
then again on the outside it does look
very similar to the galaxy nexus
especially on the front where you're
using it so much and in the united
states it does not have lte so there is
no 4g lte version you will not be seeing
a nexus 4 on verizon so that being said
do you spend extra money to lose 4g
possibly just to get the newest version
of android when you might get it later
on the galaxy nexus well that's a tough
decision so this is where the super
nexus comes in and this is a definitive
answer for people who want a definite
upgrade and are big fans of android so
combining the best of the galaxy nexus
and the nexus 4 and more this is it this
is the super nexus and uh let's go ahead
and take a look all right so on the
outside this super nexus is indeed a
black samsung galaxy s3 not the blue or
white that was out before so that by
itself is new and you can check this out
at the link right below the like button
in the description on this video and you
can see that this is version on verizon
rock in those 4g lte bands that the
nexus 4 simply does not have in fact
there are a lot of things awesome about
the samsung galaxy s3 that make it an
upgrade from the galaxy nexus like the
2100 milliamp hour battery the excellent
quality 8 megapixel camera 2 gigs of ram
and the slightly larger 4.8 inch super
amoled display and the thinness of it
all so all in all this is definitely a
hardware upgrade from the galaxy nexus
but it doesn't end there i mean we
already knew the galaxy s3 was awesome
it is pretty new phone but what really
makes it a super nexus is that this is a
rooted galaxy s3 which has allowed me to
flash the latest version of cyanogenmod
10 which is a rom based on stock android
4.1.2 jelly bean in order to get sand
engine mod on your device you do need to
be rooted and you can check the
description for more information on
whether your phone can run this rom or
not but basically if you google it and
you find instructions you are pretty
much set cyanogenmod is awesome for a
couple of reasons first of all it has
this sweet new lock screen with the
weather on the center clock up top and
you can add shortcuts to pretty much any
application you want here on the lock
screen and when you unlock you'll see it
gives this beautiful nice clean look of
stock android the way google intended it
to be and it looks great with the black
galaxy s3 and the black notification
blur and of course the black wallpaper
and yes i will have a link to that
awesome wallpaper in the description of
this video furthermore cyanogenmod
brings a few helpful features that
actually add to the stock android
experience so things like the quick
setting controls and the notification
bar are a prime example one of the
biggest features of cyanogenmod since
day one i think this is even faster way
to edit your wi-fi or auto-rotate or
brightness settings or whatever than you
see in android 4.2 which actually takes
an extra click this super nexus is also
really fast not just excellent in
benchmarks and good looking on paper
fast but it actually delivers a really
buttery smooth user experience even if
you're using a nightly version of
cyanogenmod it's stable for the most
part and for those of you worried about
it being beta you can flash a milestone
version of cyanogenmod which is tailored
specifically to be daily driver material
i've had pretty much zero crashes so
again this delivers a nexus-like
experience with even more awesome
hardware and add-ons all over the place
and speaking of add-ons i have actually
added a few things to this rom that
didn't come with it originally to make
it even more of a super nexus so i
flashed the android 4.2 gesture keyboard
that lets you swipe across the words to
type i definitely have a video about
some of these things coming up in the
near future but you might have heard of
the new keyboard it's very cool i also
flashed the new android 4.2 camera and
gallery the new camera is definitely
awesome i'll have more info again on
this camera in a new video but what's
really impressive is it lets you take
much more in-depth panoramas and even
this thing called photo spheres which
are sort of like street view when done
properly very very cool the new gallery
is definitely a lot faster than the old
one and it also has some neat features
that actually let you add instagram like
filters to photos on the fly if you're
into that kind of thing and if you've
taken a photo sphere and you hit that
new photo sphere button in the gallery
you can view and pan around the photo
like you're standing there in real life
and even share this exact experience on
google plus which allows you to do the
same thing like i said it's just like
street view very cool there's also a new
android 4.2 clock app and a few other
minor updates and all of this on top of
the lte speeds that some of us just
can't live without and you've got
yourself a hell of a phone in the black
galaxy s3 also known now as the super
nexus
so there you go guys this is the phone
that has been my daily driver now for a
little while now still on verizon
wireless it's a super nexus it's really
flashy especially with this wallpaper
you can kind of tell which one it is
from afar i really like the all black
design and the look of it but let me
know what you guys think and if you
enjoyed the video go ahead and plus one
or leave a thumbs up down below and i'll
definitely be reading through the
comments and answering as many as i can
about the super nexus again all the
helpful links are in the description to
get this going on for yourself and if
this was enjoyable make sure you
subscribe for more videos like this
either way thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you